James I've left been left scratching my
head after that press conference with
almost more questions than it answered
can you shed any light yeah you're not
the only one
Isabelle the timeline is uh significant
and it's now questionable you remember
that it was in the early hours of Friday
morning 10: to 1:00 a.m. local time to
be exact 34 hours before you heard from
the doctors there that Donald Trump
tweeted having trailed the announcement
saying he was getting tested and so on
there you are 12 50 I'm positive I'm
coid positive uh now that doctor stood
up his doctor came at the hospital and
said we are 72 hours into the diagnosis
now that would take us back to Wednesday
which is curious and it's very serious
because if you go back to Wednesday
since then Donald Trump has been to New
Jersey for Roundtable fundraisers he's
been to Minnesota for a big rally he's
met with other committees so he's been
out and about and and in close contact
with many people uh without social
distancing and without face masks um so
that's a question you know was it 72
hours as the doctor says I mean he's the
doctor uh these are men and women of
detail lives depend on them getting the
detail right why is he s saying 72 hours
and who do you believe I might say it's
been put to the White House an official
has come back with this I'll tell you
what the White House are saying uh the
doctor m say it's day three not yet 72
hours the diagnosis was made on Thursday
night so the White House is building in
some rigle room there I suppose I would
like to hear it from the doctors frankly
uh about what exactly what they meant
there's something else as well Isabelle
the doctors there were talking up the
president's condition saying he's fine
he's ready to do cartwheels out the
front door that that contrasts with what
the White House actually are saying an
unnamed official to a TV pool uh
basically communicating to the media has
said that the president's vitals over
the last 24 hours were very concerning
and his next 48 hours will be critical
in terms of his care we are still not on
a clear path to a full recovery so
that's all to altogether a more grave
assessment than what we heard from the
doctors um I think time is going to have
to untangle exactly where we are and how
he
is